we keep hearing rumors that Alex
kurtzman is going to be fired from the
Star Trek franchise I've done videos in
the past explaining why that's not
really how this works but the rumors
continue
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
we go where no man has gone before
so first of all I'm going to explain why
Alex kurtzman can't be fired from the
Star Trek franchise because he doesn't
actually work for Paramount I know
that's confusing he works for his
production company called secret hideout
Paramount have a contract with him to
develop and produce Star Trek for them
and Paramount also has first dibs on
anything non-star Trek that secret
hideout then produces
so you can't fire somebody that doesn't
technically work for you but what you
can do is cancel the contract so they
are no longer making Star Trek for you
now I think that's what a lot of people
mean when they're talking about Alex
kurtzman getting fired they're on about
actually secret how that being pushed
out the door and CBS bringing Star Trek
back in house but are there rumors to
suggest that's exactly what Paramount to
CBS are maybe planning to do well as you
know from my previous video if you
watched it if not there's a link in the
description that actually I've been
talking to quite a high up executive
person at CBS and Paramount and this
Source has been telling me that there is
a lot of internal conversations about
Star Trek at the moment I actually think
that these conversations just make sense
because Star Trek even though it is
popular has divided a lot of opinion
there are a lot of fans that really
really do don't like what Alex kurtzman
has done with Star Trek if you actually
check the comments of any Star Trek
video I've ever done you will see dozens
of comments that are very very angry
towards the Alex kurtzman era and
Paramount no they see all of this
controversy and they wonder if actually
Alex kurtzman is the person to move
forwards with Star Trek now they have
over the last couple of years trying to
bring back more original sort of Trek
Picard season 3 is the perfect example
of that and it was the most popular Star
Trek show that they've made and
Paramount really noticed so there's been
a lot of pressure on Alex kurtzman to
remove some of the ideas and some of the
things that he's been putting into Star
Trek previously stuff that he really
brought in from the JJ Abrams Bad Robot
era of movies and to go back to
something more original something that
trekkies will actually recognize now at
the moment secret hideout has this
contract with power imagine as I said
that actually runs through currently
till 2016. now that the strikes are
going Alex kirstman has approached
Paramount and CBS Studios and he wanted
to basically begin conversations on
renewing those contracts that is going
to be really important for him because
he's got things like Star Trek Academy
Star Trek 90210 coming up which won't
even be starting there till next year
2015.
12 months within when the contract is
currently supposed to end we've also got
the Michelle yeoh movie that's even
though we'll be produced within the next
12 months probably again won't be on our
screens until the end of next year they
are very interested in potentially
moving forward to Star Trek Legacy and
even though a lot of these projects are
up in the air as far as secret hideout
or aware they're all moving forwards so
they would like a new contract please
thank you very much the problem is my
source is telling me the Paramount to
track in their feet that they're not
actually very interested in going
forwards with a contract extension at
the moment apparently formally they are
saying that they don't believe contract
extension conversations right now is
appropriate and they're using the
strikes as that excuse
but internally the conversation is that
actually they would rather not have the
conversation with Alex kurtzman right
now because they're not sure they want
to extend the contract they're not sure
that they want to go beyond the current
license agreement
at the end of 2016 all of the rights for
the movies and TV shows everything will
return back to Paramount they've
licensed a lot of this stuff out and
even though paramounts still own the IP
and still can actually tell Alex
kurtzman and Seeger Hideout what to do
or what not to do there is a lot of
creative freedom involved that secret
hideout control because of those
contracts and the simplest way for
Paramount and the cheapest way for
Paramount to bring Star Trek Back
in-house is just to allow those
contracts to run out secret hideout
would no longer be the producer of Star
Trek and Paramount could either look for
a new partner or bring it back in house
and start producing Star Trek themselves
now I'm not 100 certain which plan they
are actually planning to go with
because I don't think they know all I
know is from my sources at Paramount and
again this source is in a very prominent
position I have been able to vet him I
do know he is who he says he is and I do
know he's in the position to actually be
in not only know about these
conversations but actually be involved
in them and it does seem the Paramount
are very very interested in the
possibility of cutting Alex kurtzman out
of the Star Trek franchise
and I would love to know exactly what
you think about that Prospect because it
would mean potentially a very different
Star Trek in the future it could mean
that we return to a Star Trek we find
more familiar maybe returning to a Star
Trek a little bit more like Picard
season three maybe this is how we get
Star Trek a legacy because Terry
mattalis got wrote and created in
showrun Picard season 3 isn't actually
attached to secret hideout right now
perhaps Paramount could actually bring
him in immediately as soon as these
contracts lapse and tell him to crack on
with Star Trek Legacy now that would be
very very interesting Prospect for a lot
of Star Trek fans it would mean
potentially the end of things like
strange new worlds in Star Trek Academy
maybe even lower decks and Prodigy even
though prodigious Futures in doubt
anyway
but if that meant a better Star Trek
Future Would you be on board and also
tell me exactly what you think about
Paramount internal conversations are
they sensible or is this not the time
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and you get
to see them without the adverts and for
a small contribution each month that
really supports a channel you even get a
free gift can't say fair than that also
please go and check out
sidetrack.co.uk which is our dedicated
website where stories from most of our
videos appear
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]